every retail sales person in America
just secretly wants to get through life
without ever being accused of being a
pushy salesperson and so the man in the
desert story you know the guys there's a
Cecilia story in the world I'm you can
tell I made it up because it's so silly
but the guy is because God lives on an
oasis in a desert he looks out one day
and there's a man that's been obviously
stranded in the desert for days kind of
kind of approaching a serious
approaching death or something he's like
well and so what happens in retail in
the retail industry is people rush up to
him and give him a glass of water and
then they he drinks the water and they
pat themselves on the back and the man
of the desert wanders off some more and
they're feeling great about themselves
you know hella I got the guy a glass of
water and so we there's so much more
that you can do for him you need to
intuit his needs and you know let's see
he needs more than water he's been out
there for days he needs food he might
need electrolytes not just water so
let's give him some Gatorade or you know
he needs to call his family and let them
know that he's okay you know and and not
to mention aloe vera and all of that so
you're really the man in the desert
you're fulfilling his needs and to
itting is knees and filling them through
conversation and through it's hard work
but you know you're doing all of that
then you can feel you know good about
yourself man in desert puts the moral
imperative if you will on selling rather
than not selling somebody that really
understands the mountain desert a story
will understand that selling and service
are the same thing we're not training
people to sell up sell this mortgage but
just help them in the true sense of the
word just help the customer and the true
since the word and you can only help the
customer and help the company or you can
hurt the customer and hurt the company
if you wimp out and give them a glass of
water then you're just kind of wimping
out because you're afraid of being seen
as a pushy salesperson you're hurting
the customer
and you're hurting the company so if
there's a woman in the container store
closet section and she's got a tie rack
in one hand and a shoe rack in the other
hand I mean she obviously has a closet
somewhere that's driving her crazy and
and you can conclude that fairly safely
and if you let her get out of there with
those two items she's still going to
have a closet was driving her crazy but
the ties and the shoes would be a little
bit better off what you can do is you
know cause interaction with her to find
it and take a complete closet approach
to really kind of redoing our whole
closet and what that will usually lead
up to is a customer that's vastly
happier because she got a problem solved
so you got her and she dancing in the
closet because it's so perfect that's
what we're trying to get we're trying to
get what we call the customer dance then
you have a really delighted customer
who's coming back quickly who's so
delighted with her closet that she's
showing her sister-in-law and her
next-door neighbor that closet and then
they're coming in because they want they
want that feeling too and they're like
emotionally thrilled with this closet or
pantry or toy storage solution or
whatever and that's how we build our
business in an old market or in a new
market and ultimately what people want
is they want to feel emotional about the
brands and about the pratha take this
stuff home and they live with it for a
very long time and they either cust you
every time they see it or they smile and
they're very very happy about it so we
talk about that you can get people to be
emotional even about something as
pedestrian as a trash can we probably
have the world's I think we're the
world's best selection of trash cans and
even a trashcan can make you smile if
you have this man in the desert
interaction between customer and sales
person she's got to like or trash can so
much as it fits in that corner perfectly
you love the way the petal opens and
clothes closes you're you're actually
kind of proud of your trashcan yer
you've considered showing it off to
houseguests that you have over its stuff
and proudly saying you know that's my
trashcan what you think about you know
my trash can and that's man in the
desert selling you're just trying to
help her figure out what she needs to
feel that way
and people want emotion